what came first the idea for the story
or the look of the film and the very
unique way that you made it I mean it
was a little bit concurrent but I
definitely I had I had an idea for at
least some of these characters and the
story mainly John Hawkes character and
it kind of had I was figuring out what
to do with these characters and then
around that time I kind of got this idea
to experiment with these really long
takes which is something I hadn't done
before I just thought well that's a
sometimes you just need a little bit of
structure to to wrangle all your
characters and ideas into and that
seemed to be just something interesting
that got me going and why long takes in
in film and 35 millimeter because you
know especially not with digital
technologies and stuff like that yeah I
don't I've never shot on digital don't
want to shoot on digital this was yeah
and especially I guess I had never seen
a shot this long on 35 millimeter
because we shot in the old technical
process which had kind of died out in
the 70s and so most of the famous long
takes in cinema like touch of evil and
the player and all the shots in rope
there they all max out at 11 minutes or
so because that's what a roll of film
typically in 35 millimeter will give you
but Tecna scope is it's got that if you
guys don't know it's got kind of smaller
frame sizes so you can cram more more
frames in there and it's like a
two-for-one special so with the same the
same thousand foot load that Hitchcock
used on rope because we're shooting a
techna scope we got 22 minutes out of
that and I just thought wow I don't know
if anyone's ever used this format in
this way before and I just thought it
would be interesting well Alex can I ask
you when did you come on the project how
was your experience with your work for
the film yeah I mean I came on um I
guess pretty close after Dennis finished
the script and he reminded me the other
i guess a couple weeks ago well I did
come on right after this
and then so I've been there through the
entire casting process and the long
agonizing time it took to get John
Hawkes on board down to all the research
that we had to do with all these acts
each act we shot separately so it was
almost like shooting a short film five
times but we so there was so much that
went into each act so much preparation
Theresa and I were talking earlier that
no other film does each person on the
set know exactly what everybody's doing
because we all had to kind of be a part
of all the jobs because I mean down to
like the grip who he was the one just an
enact the drive-in act just the camera
all the way to yeah running it was just
it was it was just so much prep involved
for each act was there one that was
specifically more difficult than then
then the other five I don't thinks I
mean they all had their challenges I
mean the first one we did was act 3 the
the strip club scene and you know you're
talking about live music acts going on
in between two locations just having to
deal with a sound person having to
travel to you know the both locations
having to deal with the Steadicam up
having to do a 22-minute scene with a
thousand-foot mag on a steady kamarag
which we learned was not possible so we
ended up coming up with a unique way to
do that Dennis do you want to talk about
it well basically we just yet this thing
was so heavy these guys could not and
these were big guys and they couldn't do
it and they start tapping me on the
shoulder like we should find some
curtains to go through and hide a cuts
I'm like no no no no we're not doing any
of that malarkey we are we're going to
do it for real so these guys came up
with this idea to actually hand the
camera off mid take like a baton with
everything's still rolling the first
time it happens in the movie is when
John he leaves the strip club he walks
down the sidewalk into the other bar and
he goes up to order a drink at the bar
and then he's just kind of lost in
thought thinking about what just
happened
next door and that whole time they've
they've docked the camera and the first
guy who just did 10 or 11 minutes he
detaches the Steadicam arm the other guy
was hiding in the bathroom he comes out
with his own vest and arm and he kind of
slips in and then goes on and does the
next 10 or 11 minutes and i napped for
in the drive-in we did that kind of
switcheroo two or three times yeah yeah
because that was even crazier we were
covering like 15 acres in that scene and
they're going up and down rickety
staircases so that was a lot I want to
ask about the locations too I mean were
you Trish already involved in scouting
locations and what were you looking for
yeah I only designed Act three and four
so that's the strip club and the and the
drivin but I prepped all of them with
Dennis and we took great care at every
single location to the blocking was more
part of my job than it has ever been
before and I'm really grateful for it
actually because since then it's become
something that I've really rolled into
like my conversation with directors more
and more but it's I mean we spent days
sometimes just walking through each
location is this really what's going to
work for us like what the throw was from
the drive-in like you know to the screen
like talking about like the lumens like
how things are going to show up just
walking things out over and over and
over again and that happened at every
location i mean we saw multiple hotels
and like walked down to hotel is that
before me asking we wound up at the
beverly hills yeah the beverage beverly
hilton yeah yeah but we had looked at
like um the Huntington in Pasadena like
lots of grand hotels and we were
counting steps down places and walking
pacing or there's so much pacing and let
you know we just really am yeah there is
a lot that went into it well and you
know I want to ask Robert and been to
like obviously everything's with with
with long takes that it's such a visual
thing but sound is so huge for creating
that illusion and I just want maybe
maybe asking you first pan about what
was it like mixing it make me
seeing this to make it look what it is a
single take it's tough you know usually
people start and stop and there are
places for us to hide and get in and out
different takes but it's a strange
experience to have such long pieces of
sound and there was a there was a
phenomenal amount i mean the crew was
you could hear they were being
conscientious but when you have that
many people you have camera operators
and sound guys lots of crew so there's a
lot of places where we had to really
work hard to get rid of those extraneous
sounds I mean I've worked on one long
take film before and because this was
much more challenging because of the
locations there was a lot of outdoor
work there's a lot of in and out of
different rooms and it's one of the most
challenging things I've ever done and
for them in the music ID when did you
come on board how did you conceive of
the the music in the film yeah well one
would when I saw the film I didn't have
act one yet and you know there's so much
source music and you know radios playing
and music in the strip club and all of
that sort of thing and and something
about the long takes makes it feel very
at the time it felt very raw to me it's
all very real I here in a place and I
thought well if you could if you cover
this film and music it's going to it
might break that illusion and I don't
really want to do that so but the
concept was so interesting to me as well
I have to work on this film no matter
what even though maybe there isn't much
place for me as a composer so Dennis and
I got together and and I said well I
realized this isn't the composer's movie
and I'm okay with that and he said well
I didn't originally think he didn't you
didn't think were going to have a score
initially but once the decision I think
had been made to include it he was of
the opinion that we should just feature
the music as much as possible so if it's
in there instead of doing an ambient
thing and kind of hiding we would say
nowhere if we're going to have score
we're going to really do it so that was
really exciting to meet I think was more
I wasn't sure if we could afford a score
it spends all our money on
Bob Dylan tracks and all this stuff but
I I mean I love score and that's yeah
one thing we talked about is like if
we're going to do this I know there's
already a lot of died jetta commute
going on in this but I I don't want to
just have you come in and fill in the
blanks with some ambient droning or
something like I want real themes for
each character and I want people walking
out humming these things and not like a
kind of hidden score which happens a lot
these days I wanted a kind of a old old
school romant lush romantic symphonic
score and and you brought it yeah so we
did it was it was it was it was a nice
surprise that meeting anything and Val
can I asked like just you're obviously
in it you know just just the movement
yeah I'm obviously and then just the
movement just you know what was your
experience but you know was it how
different was it from anything else
you've been in there's a lot more
rehearsal just in the nature of those
long takes it has to be very
choreographed it's different in that way
and then you get to shooting and your
you feel entirely prepared it almost it
lives in you even more than other parts
have lived in you I quite enjoyed the
experience because with a 20 minute roll
you can really live and become the
character there's no cuts there's no you
know it's just it's all or nothing so
you have to completely commit not that
you wouldn't in any other scene but it's
almost like theater in that way and when
it comes together it's magical it feels
so much more magical and cinematic and
special when you can at the end of
nineteen twenty minutes you've
interacted with four actors you've you
know outside dealt with outdoor audio
inside many rooms it's just it's pure
magic at the end when it works so I
think you can really get into character
and it's really much more rewarding when
you nail it how many takes me you know
rehearsals or takes would you did you
use in the film for either Valerie well
we did about 10 complete takes for each
of the five scenes and almost invariably
it was the last one of the day because
everyone's adrenaline was up
we know all right the sun is coming down
or the sun's about to come up this is
our last chance and so everyone is just
on the top of their game even more so in
that yeah you're seeing is definitely
the the last of the day and there was a
rainbow after the same that we I think
all of us knew that was probably going
to be the take as we said cut and
they're all like you and Sidney we're
all excited even Jeff Fahey was like see
that rainbow update like everyone was
excited excited thinking that was a sign
yeah well we're out of time but I want
to thank you all for being here today
and yeah it was an honor it looked
beautiful thank you guys for coming out
on a Saturday thank you